والى فرنسا مشاهدينا التي تستعد ليوم جديد
من التظاهرات والاضرابات بدعوه من
النقابات العماليه احتجاجا على رفع سن
التقاعد حيث سيشمل هذا التحرك العمالي
والشعبي الجديد عده مدن فرنسيه هذا هو
اعلن وزير الداخليه ان 11 الفا و500 عنصر
عنصر امن سيواكبون المشاركين في هذا اليوم
الاحتجاجي
وكانت جوله المحادثات التي جرت الاربعاء
بين رئيسه الوزراء
وممثل النقابات العماليه عفوا قد انتهت
الى الفشل كما قال نقابيون شاركوا في
الاجتماعات
لم تظهر اي انفتاح لناحيه تحقيق مطلبهم
بسحب قانون رفع سن التقاعد
[موسيقى]
ومن باريس مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مدير مكتبه
العربيه حسين خنيبر اهلا بك حسين وكيف بدت
باريس وبقيه المدن الفرنسيه صباح اليوم
والتي تستعد لهذه التظاهرات
الحاشده حسين
نعم احمد صباح الخير هذا التحرك الواسع
النطاق اليوم الذي سيشمل عده مدن عبر
فرنسا عده مدن كبرى ومتوسطه وصغرى هو
التحرك الحادي عشر اليوم الحادي عشر
للاحتجاج على رفع سن التقاعد التظاهر
الاكبر ستكون بطبيعه الحال في العاصمه
باريس حيث سينطلق المتظاهرون عند الساعه
الثانيه من بعد الظهر من ساحه انفاليد نحو
ساحه ايطاليا
التحرك سيشمل عده قطاعات ابرزها النقل
والصحه والطاقه والتعليم والنقابات بدات
تحركا من نوع جديد وردتنا قبل دقائق من
الان معلومات عن تحرك بدا بعيده الساعه
العاشره بالتوقيت المحلي اي قبل ربع ساعه
من الان بدا في احد اقسام مطار شارل دو
غول هذا التحرك يعيق حركه المسافرين هو
القسم الدولي من مطار شارد غول هناك رحلات
داخليه ورحلات اوروبيه ورحلات مع مناطق
اخرى في العالم تنطلق من شارد جول الاغلاق
الحاصل في هذا المطار حاليا يشمل طائرات
يشمل رحلات نحو كل من الامارات وقطر
والمانيا وكندا طبعا هو تحرك عابر ستقوم
القوى الامنيه
بمحاوله اعاده ترتيب وتنسيق الوضع بشكل
تتمكن هذه الشركات التي اطالتها هذه
التحركات من ان يعني تقوم بتنظيم رحلاتها
بشكل المعتاد كما ذكرت احمد
11,500 عنصر امن سيواكبون هذه التظاهرات
عبر فرنسا من بينهم
4,200 في باريس وحدها كما توقع مذكره
للاستخبارات الداخليه ان يشارك ما بين
600,800 الف شخص في التظاهرات عبر فرنسا
من بينهم ما بين 60 الف وتسعون الفا في
العاصمه وحدها انهم امتحان قوه جديد بين
الحكومه والشارع الحكومه تحاول
يعني اعطاء الانطباع بانها تتعاون لكن
النقابات قالت ان المحادثات التي جرت بين
ممثليها ورئيسه الوزراء اليزابيث لم تكن
مثمره ولم تؤدي الى اي نتيجه احمد طيب
حسين فيما يتعلق يعني لو عقدنا مقارنه
بسيطه بين اعداد المشاركين في هذه
التظاهرات
الان ومنذ بدايه هذه الازمه هل نتحدث عن
مسار انحداري لهذه الاعداد ام على عكس
مسار تصاعدي
هو تصاعدي على المستوى السياسي لكنه
انحداري نسبيا على مستوى المشاركين في
التظاهرات والذين تتراجع اعدادهم نسبيا من
يوم احتجاجي الى يوم اخر الحكومه تراهن
على تعب المتظاهرين وتراهن على تراجع هذه
الاعداد اقول تراجع نسبي فقط وليس تراجعا
كبيرا والشارع عبر النقبات واحزاب اليسار
يراهن على مواصله التحرك وصولا الى اليوم
الذي سيصدر فيه المجلس الدستوري حكمه في
قانون رفع سن التقاعد المجلس الدستوري
سيعلن حكمه يوم الرابع عشر من هذا الشهر
الحكومه لا تتحدث عن مخارج حتى الان لكن
بعض المراقبين لهذا الوضع يقولون ان ثم
احتمالات في الافق هل يلجا ماكرون الى حل
هذه الحكومه وتشكيل حكومه جديده هل يلجا
الى استفتاء هل تحصل مفاوضات جديده مع كل
ذلك لناحيه المفاوضات مرمون بقرار المجلس
الدستوري اما انه سيقبل قانون رفع سن
التقاعد ويعتبره دستوريا بكامل بنوده ام
انه سيرفض بعض البنود فيعادي التفاوض حول
هذا البعض المرفوض او انه
يقبل القانون تماما وهذا يحرك الشارع
مجددا لانه سيثير غضبا في الشارع واذا رفض
المجلس الدستوري قانون رفع سن التقاعد فان
على الحكومه ان تقوم بخطوات جديده وتعود
الى التفاوض من النقطه الصفر احمد شكرا لك
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من باريس
كنت معنا مدير مكتب العربيه حسين قنيبر
تحيه حسين